who will become india number one do you
think like i guess in the near future
wow it's an interesting question this is
a similar similar question to who will
become world number one yeah maybe we'll
have the same answer
um
yeah vishan and of course um
a special player for a long time and uh
even if his ranking
drops or drops it doesn't take anything
away from like his greatness um he's
achieved like so many things that all
these youngsters who have enormous
talent
they're right now only dreaming of that
of course
um
that said okay if you did this i think
at some point i would guess uh
vidit might be uh in the number one
but he has to
i think there's a window for him i feel
um because i would guess that one of the
many
youngsters
are likely to at some point uh reach the
heights that are like so high
that it's gonna be hard
for a top player like we did even to
compete with
uh and there could be like a really
great player
like
a special player coming up that would
like just be i don't know world number
one or
um
world champion or whatever and uh right
now any of the youngsters we know can
can be that uh
or um you know so we don't know yet and
at some point i was talking to a friend
of mine and i was telling him like you
know there are not
that many young indian youngsters i mean
like there are many but there's not that
many like okay there is okay
there is prague there's no hell there's
gokish
okay maybe there is raunak okay
okay maybe there is arjun yeah
eric i see yes and
and we started to like coming up with
more and more uh
names you know maybe there's abimenu
maybe and we started like coming up with
like 15 nations i would be like yeah
maybe there are many youngsters really
many indians